the southern colombian city of cali has
a long reputation for drug trafficking
crime gangs
and above all violence it's now the
center of an
uprising against the government over
economic reforms
and hardships caused by covid death
stalks the streets of cali once again
every day
pop-up barricades in the commercial
center of the city are common
masked youths force drivers into snarled
up detours
lighting fires and waiting for trouble
and it is often violent
police use live rounds and anti-protest
vigilantes
shoot indiscriminately
dario rodriguez joined one of the
barricades a man on a motorcycle drove
up and shot him in the head
he was in intensive care for 17 days
against the odds
he survived but is weak despite his
injuries
he has no regrets
dario and his family blame the
government and its supporters
and they have no doubt this was a
premeditated attack
this is a story about poverty and
inequality
in the toughest areas of cali poverty
and unemployment is endemic
whole districts are now blockaded from
the authorities and in the void
gang members are thriving
masked men man the barricades and
control all entry
we saw men with guns getting through
their lines is difficult and dangerous
they're well organized they communicate
continuously with walkie-talkies
and the district is divided into sectors
gang member or revolutionary it's
difficult to know
but the commander of barricade one
illustrates how volatile this situation
is
yes
as it stands right now it's difficult to
see how the violence that's claimed the
lives of over 60 people in less than two
months will end
both sides are firing live rounds in
built-up communities
what's unusual about this protest
movement is how long it's gone on for
it's weeks and weeks usually protests in
colombia last a couple of days
it's in the favelas the poorest parts of
the whole of the country and of course
latin america that the
anger has been growing for a very long
time the government
just simply refuses to negotiate though
at all until the barricades that have
effectively cut off the favelas from the
outside world are removed and they won't
remove them
so we are at a complete impasse and
every single day people are dying
in conflict between the police and the
ordinary people
and in the background drug gangs are
moving in at the same time
absolutely everyone says that's
happening because there's no law and
order here now
the clashes have been remarkably violent
and the police have been condemned by
many for their heavy-handed tactics
against the demonstrators
they accept some of the criticism but
say they're being fired at and intend to
smash the gangs
this is their video
nope
despite appearances there is an
overwhelming tension on the barricaded
streets now close to traffic
inside mass men play with little
children
is this a revolutionary leader or a
gangster grooming new recruits
in this febrile chaos he might well be
both
stuart ramsey sky news cali colombia